je vous présente le jardin d'italie je
suis toni menti aux rennais maître
restaurateur chef des cuisines des pin
bonne quarantaine d'années père de samy
structures qui existent déjà depuis 15
ans à dans l'occupation des différentes
poste j'en suis et je reste chef des
cuisines je suis absolument le seul
maître à bord mais j'ai quand même un
second qui m'a si govou très bien que ça
fait sept ans qu'il est avec moi au
chaud j'ai une troisième personne au
froid et au dessert une quatrième
personne effectivement à la pizza ça se
presser cutif de la cuisine mais il est
clair que tout le monde sait remplacer
tout le monde ayant salle effectivement
les postes ne sont pas aussi bien
partagée puisque j'ai deux apprentis et
en commun c'est un peu juste fait
qu'effectivement le maître d'hôtel sur
ma femme ça devient un petit peu
difficile pour nous deux pour assumer à
chaque fois une maladie ou un accident
nous recherchons actuellement un chef de
rang et le professionnalisme qui me faut
dans ce type de personne que nous
recherchons 6 ans minimum avec deux ans
d'expérience qui connaissent le métier
et qui connaissent un petit peu quand
même la cuisine pour laquelle ils vont
travailler ça nous permettra d'aller
beaucoup plus vite dans l'apprentissage
et de façon à ce qu'ils puissent assumer
directement dans son rôle et
éventuellement un ou deux extras pour le
week end parce que le week-end on a une
influence que beaucoup plus importante
et cela ça doit rester dans le cadre de
chef de rang à la limite de mes chefs
mais il faut impérativement que
quelqu'un qui sache où fally mise en
place qu on ne peut pas se répéter mille
fois mais tu es mal parme était mal
fermée hermétiquement cuillère concert
poser une assiette sur table koné un
sourire qu'on sache le servir
agréablement cela c'est des choses qu'on
apprend dans l'apprentissage
quand on arrive à être des
professionnels de ce métier et c'est
exactement ce que je recherche
actuellement pour la chaîne bien ce qui
concerne le deuxième poste recherché
d'urgence dans cette maison un second de
cuisine ou en troisième des cuisines
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui sache est
tout chaud ou froid en cuisine ça
devient urgent parce qu'elles effectuent
magna les congés annuels qui s'approche
à la limite il y en a quelques uns en
septembre j'en ai un autre qui se marie
en plus ça fait qu'obligatoirement ce
poste-là il va falloir les remplacer ne
serait ce qu'avec des cdd puis si les
personnes sont vraiment capables dans
les gares d'un cdi dans sa crypte si
accord il ya une impossibilité
complémentaires pour créer un poste de
travail pour pouvoir faire en sorte à ce
qu'il y a un chômeur de moins déjà et
nous on trouve ce qu'on a besoin pour
pouvoir continuer à accueillir notre
clientèle